bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va
reparler d'eux est qu on est dans son
super loft oui la roquette à paris et on
a plein de votre téléphone vous montrez
jolie téléphone avec des dos magnifique
jusqu'au vous avez jamais vus vraiment
un touché qui est très sympa alors on a
un écho et là on a un autre écho là on a
encore un autre et colas est encore une
autre et colin et ça on en parle
[Musique]
bon grégory est ce que tu peux me parler
un peu de eko eko ça un peu plus de deux
ans aujourd'hui us eco ça appartient à
une entreprise qui s'appelle modelabs
wave wallabies historiquement c'est un
gros sinistres un grossiste un
distributeur
donc on intervient entre les industriels
et les clients dits les rites et l'heure
auxquelles tout ce qu'on a l'habitude de
connaître qui ont pignon sur rue pour
distribuer les mobiles et de
l'électronique non plus qu'il y ait ce
pour quoi on a créé qu'on a créé qu'on
pourquoi parce que en fait quand on
regarde le périmètre aujourd'hui le
marché
on se rend compte que les industriels
historiques ils ont grandi aujourd'hui
ils veulent faire beaucoup de valeur et
ils ont délaissé les segments plus
entrée de gamme donc le 0 à 100 49 ans
nous on est distributeur de ces gens là
donc on voit ce qu'ils font tous les
jours puisque on les entend les
accompagne dans cette démarche sur le
marché donc on se dit par rapport à ça
ça pourrait être très intéressant
d'aller positionner une marque un petit
peu habile un petit peu jeune un petit
peu fun on en parlera après justement
pour compléter ce qui se fait avec les
marques historiques
la gamme de 2018 sur les smartphones va
être décomposée en trois sous catégories
aujourd'hui on se voit pour parler
design sur la première sous catégories
qu'on va appeler la gamme start c'est un
produit qu'on appelle lolli met d'accord
d'accord c'est un produit
un écran de 4,3 g comme tu peux
constater segment produits la partie
avant le produit qu'on appelle
développement du tibet et de la couleur
du produit généralement sur la plupart
des produits dans se sépare de rire je
vais retrouver enfin d'un petit guide et
noir et blanc nous ont fait le choix
d'un point de vue design d'avoir un
petit piqué de la couleur du terminal
d'accord d'accord et il le point là où
on parlait qui est très important c'est
la partie arrière du produit sur chaque
produit des vêtements très maintenant
que tu vas voir il ya vraiment un gros
travail de fond fait sur le design donc
là on est sur des petits cercles
concentriques avec une petite bande en
dessous qui rappelle on le distingue
peut-être pas très bien mais une petite
pompe qui rappelle que le produit est
destiné aux ans est bon à fait différent
puisque ça quand c'est l'adn dont on
parle est totale ça c'est un produit qui
est 16 giga au niveau de la mémoire rom
et un giga au niveau de la prom' delà de
la mémoire ram c'est un produit qu'on va
retrouver dans les jours qui viennent à
50 points 0,97 et ses clients
[Musique]
notre adn il est fondamentalement basé
sur de gros pignon le premier pilier
ça va être le design est bien entendu ce
qui est très important pour nous c'est
d'offrir malgré tout ça d'offrir une
très bonne technologie à nos clients
parce que c'est pas parce qu'on a décidé
qu'on allait mettre ou qu'on n'est plus
contraint financièrement qu'on va pas
acheter un produit à plusieurs centaines
d'euros
elle unifie les on n'a pas le droit
d'avoir un téléphone qui offre les
prestations dernier cri le lecteur
d'empreintes 4g deuxième produit il
produit qu'on appelle surf c'est un
produit 5 pouces à écran 18 9e et
j'insiste venue de là dessus pourquoi
parce que soit ce segment que je ne
retrouve nulle part le fait qu' on est
un écran de ratio 18 9e d'accord a mené
plus tôt en général sur des ratios 16/9
ça c'est bien pourquoi parce que la
surface occupe l'écran bien plus
importantes sur un 10 mineurs quand tu
vois ce terminal a quasiment qu'un écran
t'as pas de porc ça me faisait des
essais bordelaise dont on se parle je
vais me faire reproduit un look très
joli à côté de ça il est 3g
il est 16 giga de mémoire 1 giga de
mémoire vive de rome et là où on se
permet de naples et soeurs sont encore
une fois c'est surtout sur l'arrière qui
a travaillé de son fantastique qui est
fait par le designer avec des petites
vagues ça peut qu'apprendre ta planche
de salut ça va être ça en transit qui
vraiment très jolie et très très joli
design super design dispo dans quelques
semaines 69 euros 90 à dos jacques
produire vraiment sans adhérer design
chaque produit à sa patte
cette année il ya beaucoup de couleurs
on va fêter l'été 2006 avec deux
couleurs c'est plutôt punchy et c'est un
peu l'adn de la boîte donc c'est assez
là c'est un peu notre truc dont je vous
ai des smartphones avec un on a après
touché différents au dos de chaque
appareil oui c'est quoi il dépend
comment on est arrivé à vous dire on va
se différencier cette manière florent
notre designer il il a travaillé dans la
mode il a travaillé dans différents
domaines d'activité avant de nous
rejoindre
et effectivement il se dit pourquoi pas
aujourd'hui à l'heure où les téléphones
ont quand même se ressemblent énormément
un écran reste un écran en écran tactile
reste un écran tactile comment on va
différencier sans terminal la trace
avant ça reste un écran donc tu peux pas
faire grand chose
oui mais la face arrière par contre
c'est autant donner une expression
laisser là où justement il dit mme à moi
ma différence à sion là où nous et qu on
va aller se différencier de nos marques
concurrentes ça va être ce soir s'est
taillé une vraie créa qui fait alors
rien c'est un vrai parti pris assez au
près par les salles ça change
complètement et tous en marche et pour
le coup c'est vraiment novateur sa porte
vraiment quelques qu'on passe au
troisième produit de la gamme
d'une vient balayer deux produits 3g on
passe à notre premier produit cat est
toujours 16 giga de mémoire interne
toujours un giga de mémoire vive
tu as une sensation qui est assez
sablonneuse bien évidemment encore une
fois on retrouvera des mines du produit
disponibilité aussi dans quelques
semaines 79 euros 80 alors question par
rapport à des concurrents comme ricco
qui aussi pression sur l'entrée de gamme
oui comment est ce que vous vous situez
pense que on met vraiment un accent
encore plus fort sur le design et toute
la cosmétique je parlais du paquet nié
toute cette cosmétiques ça c'est
vraiment l'année
on va pas la lancer un produit ici on
n'est pas nous convaincu au départ de
course assez bien et dernier produit qui
vient compléter cette gamme start
il s'appelle quoi quartz pourquoi
puisque sur l'arrière on retrouve comme
des visions de cristaux de quartz
toujours cette même bande dessinée aux
ancêtres
on accorde donc vraiment l'apathie zain
le produit 4g le produit et 16 giga de
mémoire interne
il est un giga de mémoire vive les 5
pouces 5 ans 18 9e
il a un lecteur d'empreintes digitales
et ça c'est un produit que l'on va
retrouver également dans différents
coloris à 99 euros 4 e
[Musique]
non je dirais que je fais tout ce que je
sais aussi qu'on sait bien c'est mon
double magnifique pour les judokas ont
résumé de la gamme que tu viens de voir
c'est quoi c'est quand on se disait tout
à l'heure on parle d'un design super
sympa super original on a de la couleur
comme ça ça dynamise et on sait que
cette année aux couleurs
et on essaye de proposer ça pour des
budgets qui sont super accession
vraiment mal et ça c'est la dlc
disponible dans tous les réseaux de
distribution y avait quasiment nouveau
dans tous les coloris et ça c'est bien
son besoin de déficit alors lolli ils
arrivent cette semaine en manipulant mes
clients il ya quelques jours on a le
surf qui va arriver avant début juillet
d'une ce qui arriveront la première
quinzaine de juillet pour les plus les
plus impatients dans trois semaines
c'est dispo d'accord c'est pas fait pour
mes génies tous les liens dans la
description comme ça me convient
exactement rester connecté parce que
d'ici quelques jours on va les tester
ces téléphones ont du mouron tester un
et on verra si on peut pas réserver une
petite surprise mais ça vous le verrez
d'ici quelques jours en attendant les
produits c'est vrai qu'ils sont cool
alors on reste des 60 d'entrée de gamme
on va pas leur demander de faire des
choses révolutionnaires pas demandé de
faire la plus belle photo d'avoir les
plus belles spec et pour des prix entrée
de gamme
d'un point de vue en tout cas tu
recommences 7 6 qui sont vraiment bien
donc je vous dirais sécurité parce que
on va les tester plus en détails d'ici
quelques jours
voilà un peu pour aujourd'hui dites moi
ce que vous en pensez à ce que vous
connaissiez déjà qu est ce que vous êtes
déjà client de la marque et qu est-ce
que vous avez déjà ou est-ce que vous
avez déjà passé un produit éco et puis
surtout est ce que vous pourriez
envisager dans l'instinct alors vous
avez vu il ya plein de push est
différent il ya plein de modèles
différents il ya plein de couleurs
différentes et causé une marque coop
c'est la française fait les choses très
sympas
donc on va continuer à le suivre mark et
moi tout ça en commentaire et est ce que
vous en pensez bien évidemment
je continue à les regarder et puis une
soirée j'allais boire un coup donc je
vous dis à très bientôt temps mort un
petit loup sympathiquement bientôt